hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to give you
an overview about the property market
what's going on right now and what's
happened not only this year but over the
last few years
because the way to predict the future is
always to look at the trends and the
past to see what's happening
so right now we are in a boom there's a
property boom going on
this is not just in the uk by the way
this is happening generally across the
world i mean i've got students
in 42 different countries and in a lot
of different countries there's booming
the governments
are introducing people to spend more and
property prices are being pushed up now
in the uk
what's going on what's happened well i'm
going to take you right back
to 2016.
2016 in the month of june was when
brexit was first announced that it was
going to be happening
52 of people in the uk ruled in favor
of our country leaving the eu
so this happened in 2016. now some
people were very happy probably 52
some people were very sad but everybody
was confused nobody knew what was going
to happen
no one knew exactly what the outcome of
this was going to be there was talk of a
referendum
and whenever there's confusion whether
whenever there's uncertainty
it always affects house prices
negatively during all this confusion and
this uncertainty then we had 2017.
so what happened in 2017 well it was not
a
great year for most property investors
or most landlords
2017 in the month of april section
24 was introduced and announced
april 2017. section 24 was that nasty
tax rule
that really really came in hard on a lot
of landlords
and again people were saying i'm out i
don't want to invest in property anymore
and prices really weren't knocked by
that um
2018 in fact the whole of 2018 and the
whole of 2019
during those two years property prices
didn't really move i mean generally
speaking property prices go
up but there was so much confusion
uncertainty the government seemed to be
attacking landlords
that prices really really didn't move
much so according to nationwide
property prices went up by around about
two percent
that's not a lot two percent the whole
of 2018 and 2019. so over 24 months
house prices went up about 2 that is not
a lot at all
then that's that's those four years so
those four years generally in the uk
house prices are pretty static not
really doing much then
we have 2020. now 2020
january the 31st we actually
left the eu so brexit happened
we left the eu now whether you think
that's a good thing or a bad thing what
happened was
when we left suddenly people oh wow
there's no second referendum
we left and a lot of confidence came
back
and property prices started to begin to
go back up in 2020
um i don't know why i've just put 2021
2020.
property prices began to go back up and
at this point january 2020
i was excited i was saying okay this is
good prices are going to go
up and then no one could have predicted
but sort of january february time that's
when the virus happened
and in april we went into a full
lockdown in the uk so let's just talk
solely about 2020 i'm going to talk you
through january
right up until october where we are
right now what's happened to house
prices
what changes have come in and then i'm
going to predict what i think is going
to happen
over the coming months and years i've
written this down really clearly so you
can see
and all these figures are according to
nationwide they're a pretty big bank
and they know exactly what's going on
with the house prices depending on
what source you take the information
from prices might vary a little bit
but this is the gist okay so january
house prices the average house in
january 2020
was 215 000 pounds
ready to boom we're out of the eu now
everything's good we've had a swamp for
the last few years
ready to go up up up up up and that's
what started to happen so february went
up to 2-1-6
march went up to 2-1-9 and march was
when coronavirus really started coming
in there was talks of lockdown and
people were thinking is this really
going to affect house prices april
222 so it's still going up but then bang
uh
suddenly january very much april may may
house prices drop and at this point
everyone was saying you know they're
gonna crash
they're gonna they're gonna absolutely
go down like crazy rents are gonna crash
get out get out get out now i was a
little bit hit actually because in april
i put some properties on auction and
then may properties are dropping but at
this point everyone was very scared
in may june they drop again so now
property prices do
seem to be dropping june they drop and
at this point
i did a video about this and i said
rents are going to go up
i said the government are going to
encourage spending and i actually
predicted that yesterday
was going to affect house prices but
what happened was they did encourage
ham spending and they brought in stamp
duty holidays
they brought this in in july in july
that
they suddenly started to boom again has
probably suddenly started to go
up and we've seen that ever since so
july they went up to 2020
2020 and then august they went up
considerably they went up the month of
august to 224
and at this point everyone's thinking
what's going to happen you know we're in
a boom
rents are going up in fact according to
right move rents were up
generally across the whole of the uk
apart from london london rents are going
down but generally speaking rents are
going up
house branches are going up september
last month two to six they've gone up
again
how how long is this going to keep
happening well with the stamp duty
holiday that came in that came in in
july
with the bounce-back loans we've now
october what's gonna happen i think
they're gonna go up again
in october i think it's gonna go up
again in november i mean that boris
johnson's just announced that
first time buyers are gonna have 95
percent funding towards their first
first house so they're desperately
trying to keep the
property prices high there is a boom
right now
my prediction is that's going to keep
happening for a little while
but like always how to predict what's
going to happen is after
a down turn will go an upturn after an
upturn will go down
turn so with all being said my
prediction
is that 2021 we are going to see a
housing crash i've been talking about
this now for a while
again i haven't got a crystal ball i'd
love to know what you think drop it in
the comments
so what are the opportunities though
because i don't want to just be a news
reporter to you about what prices have
done
what is actually going to happen and
also how can you capitalize
on what's going on well commercial
properties
have been going down commercial prices
have been falling in fact let me just
read you an interesting stat so
bear in mind how much house prices
residentially been going up
we've got here and this is according to
business news wales
london commercial properties have
dropped by 7
between january and september in
edinburgh they've fallen by 13
in bristol they've fallen by nine
percent and this is based on
uh desk space commercial this is offices
so
my prediction i think that commercial
properties are going to continue falling
for the time being i think residential
properties are going to continue rising
in the right areas i think residential
properties are going to rise like crazy
so with that in with that being said
what a lot of people are doing right now
and in fact what i'm doing myself right
now
is buying commercial properties where
the where the rents are falling and if
the rents are falling the values are
also falling because commercial
properties are valued based on their
rents
residential properties are going up so
what a lot of
developers are doing is buying
commercial properties and converting
them
to residential properties and in june
june the 30th i believe it was was when
boris johnson did his build build build
speech where he said that there's going
to be a lot of commercial properties
where
he's going to scrap having to get
planning permission to send a commercial
property into a residential property so
there's mad opportunity and rents are
going crazy
who knows what the future holds but i
know that in a crisis
is when most entrepreneurs make money so
that's a little report on what's
happened over the last few years in
property
let me know what you think about what's
going to happen over the next few years
drop it in the comments below if this
video has been helpful please do me a
massive favor and smash the like button
also don't forget to subscribe and turn
the notification bell on because i'm
doing a lot of videos like this coming
up soon where you can maximize
off of the property opportunities here
in the uk
and also overseas so subscribe and i
look forward to seeing you on the next
video thanks for watching